séance de bouclage de l'élevage de
nathalie jeune agricultrice de 40 ans
après des études de commerce
elle reprend l'exploitation de son papa
plus qu'un métier une passion transmise
de père en fille baptisée pour le moment
pour nathalie mais j'ai réussi à la tête
tous les matins je viens je viens aider
elle me fait plaisir ah ça oui et c'est
bien ce métier que nathalie et ses
voisins agriculteurs du quartier val
d'or de rivière salée veulent faire
découvrir les 7 8 9 décembre prochain
ils organisent un village agricole par
exemple 7
ce sera une journée pédagogique donc ce
sera toutes les écoles les écoles sont
invités
vient alors le 8 et le 9 idem en famille
cette fois en famille j'ai donc jamais
tout le monde à venir en famille entre
amis qu'elle les animaux est ce qu'on va
voir ici est ce que les petits vont
pouvoir discuter avec les agriculteurs a
fait donc en fait il y aura
effectivement des cabris des moutons des
bovins donc en fait les enfants les
adultes ils pourront toucher pour poser
les questions
ils pourront manger aussi pouvait venir
effectivement avec votre pique nique ou
alors manger sur place
serge le voisin vérifie que ses
concombres sont à point l'organisation
du village agricole lui tient pas car ce
qu'on a voulu exemple ces deux théories
viles adultes la radio sur feu doux que
mettre en valeur nos produits et vous
faire un humour tous les martiniquais et
chip ou koné pour sortir valdo de
l'anonymat la rivière du quartier val
d'or sera également un point de visite
du site trois jours pour aller à la
rencontre des agriculteurs du quartier
val d'or de rivière salée
les 7 8 et 9 décembre prochains